es ist vielleicht nicht jedem bewusst
aber mit eurem smartphone habt ihr einen
wahren supercomputer in euren händen und
da steckt so viel potenzial drin
das waren es wissenschaftlich nutzen
kann und zwar jeder und genau deswegen
gibt es immer mehr projekte mit denen
man durch die rechenpower des eigenen
smartphones forschung unterstützen kann
wie das genau funktioniert und was noch
alles geht das alles und noch viel mehr
jetzigen klicks und science fiction und
tausend dank für diesen tollen
themenvorschlag von euch auf den
messengern also herzlich willkommen
die idee an sich ist nicht neu durch den
zusammenschluss von vielen rechnern
smartphones und ihrer inzwischen
extremen leistung entsteht ein
supercomputer und was da zusammenkommt
ist nicht gerade wenig heutzutage haben
smartphones jahr rund 1000 mal mehr
leistung als der computer der apollo 11
im jahr 1969 zum mond geflogen hat und
diese power kann tatsächlich
sinnvolleres bewegen als elvis zu posten
beispiel dafür ist das projekt namens
said at home das nach außerirdischen
lebensform cd at home ist eine abkürzung
für search of extraterrestrial
intelligence as rom und wurde 1999 ins
leben gerufen und auch hier stecken
viele aktive einzelrechner dahinter im
sommer 2013 beispielsweise 145000
rechner aus 233 ländern weltweit weil
sie alle zusammen erreichten eine
rechenleistung von 668 teraflops das ist
richtig krass zum vergleich der zu
diesem zeitpunkt schnellste
supercomputer schaffte 33,86 petaflops
war auf dieser großartigen ideen
basieren mittlerweile einige projekte zb
die android app htc power to give die
ebenfalls die rechenleistung zur
verfügung stellt die gerade nicht
benötigt wird das selbsterklärte motto
von htc im schlaf gutes tun denn den
berechnungen des unternehmens zufolge
könnten eine million htc one geräte
zusammen ein petaflop leisten damit
würde würden sie es dann tatsächlich
unter die top 30 liste der supercomputer
schaffen um die app zu nutzen wird
empfohlen das netz anzuschließen und das
smartphone mit dem wlan zu verbinden
beispielsweise in der nacht damit die
laufzeit nicht beeinträchtigt wird die
nutzer selbst können dann bestimmen für
welches wissenschaftlichen projekt ihre
rechenleistung genutzt werden soll
über die software bekommt das smartphone
dann datenpakete zugewiesen dass es
berechnen kann zur auswahl stehen
projekte die allesamt humanitäre und
wissenschaftliche aufgaben erfüllen
sollen das ist das ziel der idee
beispielsweise kann man den hunger der
welt bekämpfen oder krankheiten oder man
macht sich damit auf die suche nach
aliens auf der offiziellen webseite von
heute sind sehr heißes hilft mit dass
die welt nacht für nacht ein stückchen
besser wird auch du wirst dann besser
schlafen
bisher gab es durch den zusammenstoß
geballter rechenpower tatsächlich auch
schon erfolge zu vermelden
das projekt mythisches rights for the
world project also übersetzt so etwas
wie nahrhafter reis für die welt konnte
zum abschluss gebracht werden dass sie
war es hier einen besseren reis ertrag
zu erzielen und zwar indem resistente
reis stämme gezüchtet werden konnten
viel rechenpower wurde gebraucht um die
proteinstrukturen der wichtigsten reis
stämme vorherzusagen ja in diesem
kontext ist auch bank sehr wichtig diese
software plattform namens berkeley open
infrastruktur von network computing
wurde an der universität berkeley
entwickelt derzeit laufende rechnung mit
denen ein genaues 3d modell der
milchstraße erstellt werden kann sowie
die simulation von protein- faltungen
und vorhersagen zur klimaentwicklung
bank ist auch nicht nur für android
geeignet sondern auch die leerlaufzeiten
von windows mac oder linux computern
können genutzt werden
als anwender installiert man sich hier
ein kleines programm und kann damit
seine nicht benötigte rechenzeit auf
mehrere projekte aufteilen wenn ihr kein
video zu diesem thema und zu allen
anderen dem verpassen wollt dann endet
mich bei whatsapp und in anderen
messenger nur dann verpasst er kein
video denn die abo box auf youtube die
ist ja immer ein bisschen lückenhaft
über die messenger erfahrt ihr dann von
mir noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video täglich garantiert da bekommt er
auch einen link zum disco server wo ich
seit 19 fast den ganzen tag irgendwo rum
hänge einfach hier draufklicken und am
besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks
um social media abonnieren
da erfahrt ihr das neueste aus der welt
des social medias aber nicht die genau
glocke vergessen und das in dem er hier
drauf klickt und hier geht es weiter
dafür auch draufklicken der schnellste
computer der welt bis dann bleib dran